Broadwater farm in North London home of
Mark Duggan whose death sparked riots
across the capital in 2011 in the 1980s
this estate was engulfed in flames and
violence that saw a policeman murdered
for many the farm is still a potent
symbol of London's segregated
communities there's a distrust of
authority and now the housing divide has
been brought into painful relief by the
Grenville tower tragedy so how long have
you lived on the estate but but 28 to 30
years and what do you make of the
housing here that's rubbish that's
rubbish it's crammed tight can't get
anything done this windows that won't
close that God and door won't look lots
of people are angry cause they are
hundreds and hundreds of people angry
I'm surprised it's not another riot the
people living here have seen the images
of Graham for tower burning and heard
the stories of those trapped inside now
they're worried about their own homes
Michael Fleming is a builder who lives
on the estate
my house is a fire what took you up
there and open the front door you see
the fires why don't you ask Forrester
because we've got no stories if
everything is in the passage anything
we've got a store has to be in the
passage our bikes or anything
our boxes my toolboxes because there's
nowhere else in the houses we have all
one cupboard in the house apart from
kitchen cupboards people scared after
seeing what happened yeah I don't think
they are the chair of the residents
Association says that after years of
raising concerns the authorities are
still not listening do you think that um
there's been a failure to listen to
people living on housing estates yeah
sort of a no and there's a fair there
there's always a sort of a top-down sort
of policies of a dictator if you like
which is the way it's going to be
happening and totally like feel a lack
of consultation the engagement that they
talk about is fun during trust of
politicians here is low they're all the
same as the familiar refrain David Lammy
the MP for Tottenham who spent his
childhood playing in Broadwater Farm
one of the few trusted politicians a lot
time in here is quoted in happier number
28 I think my cousin's lived at justjust
up there on the top and I very much live
between their house and my house which
was just sort of parallel to this road
down here and we grew up together
do you think that things have got better
for the communities that lived on
interstates when you growing up no I
don't actually my afraid I don't think
things have got better because what
there was in the 1970s particularly was
full employment you could get a job that
was quite well-paid and you could
survive David Lammy says he understands
London's housing divides more than most
he lost a friend at Granville Tower and
is furious about the conditions many in
the capital have to enjoy fire doors
that aren't fixed is a big concern now
in many communities mistrust of the
political class runs deep if there is
any suspicion of a cover-up at gruntal
tower that will only get worse so it's
been a little over two weeks since the
ground-floor Tower tragedy you've been
talking a lot to different communities
living in similar tower blocks how have
they been reacting my sense is that if
you live in a tower block a state in
Britain in fact if you live in an estate
there's quite a lot of fear particularly
amongst the women the mothers with
children that I talk to and that fear is
linked to their their now very
questioning of the stay-put advice
worried about how they would make their
way out with their kids at two three
o'clock in the morning
and their untrusting of if you like the
authority figures that they're reliant
on to give them the best advice the
local authority the housing management
organization even the fire safety and
that's partly to do with the divide
that's open up in society the folk that
turn up to give you that advice so not
people who were living in a tower block
or even know anyone living in a tower
block it would seem so
we're not in a great place we're not in
a great place in Britain you are someone
who isn't in that camp because you of
course grew up around this estate here
you lost a friend in the Granville Tower
tragedy you must still be grieving I'm
still in shock in a sense where we don't
you know when you've when a young woman
it's just beginning her life you know no
one can brilliantly believe that she's
not here there's no way of making smoke
in your lungs or burning presentable
this it's it's horrific you touched on
this a bit earlier but do you think
people trust the authorities to get to
the bottom of what went wrong and to try
and put it right I think the
overwhelming sense from the victims is
that this is a crime that something went
so badly wrong here that it amounts to
gross negligence manslaughter
so people are hanging on that criminal
investigation and one updates about how
that's developing we've heard that a lot
of police are on the commune Oh involved
in the criminal investigation which is
good we don't know where the documents
have been seized
we don't know who's been spoken to but
that's the importance and then in
relation to the inquiry the inquiry is
about yes getting to the truth but then
also making recommendations so that can
never happen again but that's years
years away and then as always it's up to
the government of the day to act on
those recommendations and there'll be
years off by then the news agenda will
have moved on the scrutiny will have
moved on I won't have moved on and
parliamentarians likely won't have move
so our job will be to hold to account to
make sure that there is justice for
those victims but that this never
happens again
talking about that inquiry the judge
himself has said that he's doubtful that
it will be as wide-ranging that some
people hope are you worried about what
happens with that inquiring I'm
disappointing that he's expressed doubt
of that kind before even meeting the
survivors and victims this is not a
court case there's not two sides there
are survivors and victims and it seems
to me if you're leading an inquiry
you're walking with them to get to the
truth and you need to be looking at the
terms of reference and the scope of your
inquiry in partnership with those people
so I'm worried but he's kicked off the
inquiry framing it in a sort of small
tiny way and do you think he's the right
person to lead the inquiry look
politicians have to always be careful of
being in a critical place in relation to
the judiciary but he is a white
upper-middle-class man who I suspect has
never ever visited a tower block housing
estate and certainly hasn't slept
tonight on the 20th floor of lawn I hope
he will do that in the days ahead the
job is not just to be independent and
judicious I'm sure he's eminently
legally qualified of course he is it is
also to be empathetic and to work with
these people on this journey and to sit
with them and understand that their
lives were in the hands of the state and
something badly badly failed it's a
shame that we couldn't find a woman to
lead the inquiry or indeed an ethnic
minority to lead the inquiry in 2017 and
I think the victims will also say to
themselves when push comes to shove
there are some powerful people here
contractors subcontractors local
authorities governments and they look
like this judge
whose side will he be on so he needs to
get close to those victims and survivors
very very quickly and established that
he is after the truth and he's fearless
and independent and he won't be swayed
because he too is a part of the
establishment talking about walking with
victims what do you make of the
political responses on both the council
level but also the national government
level have politicians done enough to
walk with the victims well to lose
everything
sometimes the lives of other family
members but literally everything you own
to go up in flames is devastating for
any human soul but then to find that
you're not cradled and supported after
that I'm afraid as a shocking indictment
of our country and so I have to say that
we have failed as a nation and I I'm not
going to make that party political we
failed to support those people and I'm
now going to get emotional again but
that makes me very upset very upset that
we that we did that in those early days
and still today something has badly
badly got wrong on wrong in that local
authority who represents those people
but the gap between the people that
represents that is huge
now some have said that you have
suggested that there's been a cover-up
on the number of people who've died in
the ground for terror a disaster what
you said was that what people say is
that if you put the numbers out early
there could be civil unrest were you
really saying that the number of people
dead could have been covered up to
prevent riots the police have filled in
a little bit of the information we now
know there are 23 homes they don't know
how many people were in them and they
don't actually know who owned the home
leased the home ran the home so we know
a little bit more but we still don't
have a list of survivors we're not able
to subtract the amount of survivors from
the approximate number of people in the
building
we know that 80 people have lost their
lives but the view amongst the victims I
spoke to them yesterday is that many
more lost their lives and you have to
get close to these people to understand
the degree of trust and how badly they
have been let down and therefore I
believe the way to deal with that is
constant communication the communication
has been poor it's got a little bit
better in the last day or two but it's
been poor hitherto to this point
Jonathan or the shadow Chancellor said
that the victims were murdered what I
murdered no I think that's not the right
language for me the right language is
this amounts it seems to me to corporate
manslaughter or gross negligence
manslaughter Jeremy Corbyn who's also
said that what happened at Grenville
exposed the disastrous effects of
austerity was that right bearing in mind
that a lot of this cladding was put up
under a Labour government the way I talk
about it is a tale of two cities
austerity and here in London you see it
writ large but you see it in other major
cities across the country you see at one
end of the spectrum social housing a
lack of quality and indifference to
people's needs and concerns and at the
other end of London huge gentrification
huge cranes huge buildings huge resource
and you absolutely see that in the
London Borough of Kensington and Chelsea
so yes it is a tale of austerity but
it's also a tale of massive massive
growth and they are sitting deeply
divided it seems to me in Britain at
this point in time we do this interview
from the Broadwater it's taken Tottenham
for many people it's a symbol of those
divisions that you were talking about do
you think that what happened at
Granville has perhaps
exposed brought lights at some of those
splits between communities that were
here in London already and also in other
parts of the country I think at the back
end of the election and one of the
reasons why the Labour Party confounded
expectations and did a lot better on the
Jeremy Corbyn and people expected was
that actually the public were up for a
discussion about public services about
the limits of the welfare state what
we've stripped back and I think Glen
feel then happened and brings out right
to the public for its really gotten to
the heart of the Britain that I know a
Britain that likes to see itself as fair
as tolerant and and therefore is
uncomfortable with with part of the face
it's seeing back in the mirror of itself
how people in these communities been
listened to before they've not been
listening to they've not been listened
to for years and that I'm afraid that
it's not just about the last 7 years of
austerity that goes beyond party
politics hearing what they're saying
about the quality of their homes hearing
what they're saying about the kind of
support they need hearing what they're
saying about the cap on their earnings
in relation to their the jobs and their
expectations we've got very very poor at
that so poor that when people are
desperate as they are in the case of
Glenfield the way they've been treated
it's horrendous